[Music]
hello and welcome back
to the games of the week i'm grandmaster
dennis borsch
and i did want to talk about games
played by
wesley so who actually tied them other
than magnus carlsen
at this event and there were some
crucial games that i felt
that we should discuss because it
pinpoints
how wesley built up this whole event and
culminated
in him tying for first place
with carlson even though carlson had
like a dodgy start
he did actually build some momentum but
it was very important for wesley not
to lose speed and to hold when it was
necessary so first off i'm going to
start with the game
between wesley so and jeffrey zhang
and in this game wesley is going to
pinpoint and show why is he such a
strong
super grand master all right so this
game started with one e4
a typical move bestly is mostly an e4
player
even though i've seen him play d4
and he does play solid catalon lines
at times but mostly and
from his childhood he was an e4 player
c5 and c5 is somewhat of a surprise
from jeffrey jones he used to play
only spanish and
either a6 or not f6
all these big lines mostly the berlin
though
c5 which i found barely
surprising because i thought that
jeffrey would go for something solid
but probably jeffrey zhang as a
compatriot
of wesley he's looking for
a fighting game therefore they go here
i've seen jeffrey john played d6
in fact i did play jeffrey zhang and he
played the night off against me
some time ago and we had a fascinating
struggle in the bishop g5 najdorf but
that was
some time ago knight c6
and knight c6 is a direct invitation for
the swesnikov
and wesley politely refuses that
what is sort of interesting is that
wesley
does not want to see jeffrey's
preparation
and doesn't go for this line which was
actually heavily discussed
in the world championship match between
carlson and caruana
more specifically the knight d5 line
and bishop e2
but back to the game vastly sidestep
this
goes for bishop b5 and goes for a slower
game at that e6
g6 was the main way of playing
in the world championship match where
carlson more or less
survived in these positions there were
positions where
karana was pressing but in the first
games it was actually kazan who was
putting pressure on karana from the
black side surprisingly
jeffrey has other ideas and he goes for
e6
castles knight e7 and here i'm going to
stop and
kind of ponder what options there are
so originally you would go
for rook even ideas or c3d4
just building a center and that was the
way
people handled it or handled this
position
originally however here wesley comes up
with a move that became popular just
recently
he played with d4 which is nothing like
rookie one and c3 now rookie one would
say
okay i have done what i had to do with
this bishop and i'm going back
and i'm kind of asking what is your
knight on e7
doing and if d5 just d3
and it turns into a slow moving game and
if you go
c3 it more kind of revolves
around the d4 square and whether
black can actually fight back
before this clumsy knight becomes an
issue
but in any case wesley went for d4 which
is hoping
for a marotzi type of structure so c
takes d4 knight takes d4
and that's why jeffrey goes for queen b6
hitting this knight and targeting this
bishop
if you go knight g6 you're actually
allowing c4
which is what wesley is aiming to get
because in that case not only do you
have a knight
sort of weirdly placed on g6 but
you will also be a little bit cramped as
you will have
have in these usual positions
now queen b6 was played pressing on d4
pressing on this bishop i take c6
this is a must because if
you move the bishop i can take on d4
and this bishop is under attack so i
take c6
b takes c6 bishop d3 knight g6
c4 now in normal circumstances that
this would be definitely definitely
playable
for black however this knight is not
on its usual spot on f6 which is
considered
satisfactory bought it but on g6
bishop c5 knight c3 bishop d4
and here we have to stop and think about
the possibilities so i'm asking you
dear viewers what would you do here
now if black manages to
sort of box in this bishop that would
become a monster
sort of eyeing both the king side and
the queen side both the king side and
the queen side
and that is something that you
definitely want to avoid
so if we have that in mind what would be
the move that you would
consider
yeah knight d2 and that is exactly the
move
that wesley played i also see knight a4
suggested and a move that i think is
quite
nice however knight a4 right here
isn't as accurate but we're going to
come back to that one
so here lastly so plays a knight e2
just trying to smoke out this bishop now
taking this pawn is taboo because i have
rook b1
and suddenly you either use lose the
queen
or lose this bishop on b2
so zhong is forced to play bishop c5
and the next move by wesley so is
kind of what kind of differentiates him
from a gm to a super gm
and he goes for this move of rook b1
it looks like a tiny little move it
looks
harmless but in fact there is a deep
idea behind it
and the deep idea is the following in
the case of castles
b4 you again cannot capture this because
a3 and you lose the queen
and if you're forced away i can go c5
and with this bishop
an honorary french bishop you are going
to be struggling
here and why this is clearly better so
jeffrey was forced to play a5
and here comes again critical position
number two
what to do now
and this is actually what you have to do
in
positions after the opening phase
you have to get rid of your open
openness threats
and opening i mean your opponent's ideas
and
threats and also wonder what you can do
about yourself in the position
we did get rid of that bishop on d4
which is good news
however we still need to come up with a
plan to
actually press for a win
so one idea would be to go ahead and go
a3 b4
however a3 does run
into this neat little tactical trick of
bishop takes
a3 oh bishop a3 does just b
b takes a3 my bad i am
completely wrong obviously just a4 and
you stop that i completely blanked
that bishop my apologies
so you just go a4 if in case of a3
you just go a4 and then you have
no ways of stopping that
so a3 is a little bit too slow
so you should be looking for a plan
that's a bit more aggressive
and that is knight c3
and if you compare this to this position
a few moves ago
knight c3 bishop d4
does this look similar to you
knight e2 ship c5 rook b1 a5
knight c3 bishop d4 almost identical
right it's almost the same
but there is one little difference
one little difference the pawn is not on
a7
but on a5 and that's
kind of the thing and the problem
in these kind of positions that these
small details make the champion
2700 plus players notice
notice the small differences and they
exploit them
so here that's the soleplate 984
queen c7 c5 castles
and the big difference is rook e1
in case of d5 you have a move that you
wouldn't have
in the case of that pawn on a7
can you spot it
in this case actually you do have knight
b6
rook b8 bishop e3 exchanging
and with white having a clear plan
and pressure on the queen side that is
clearly
better now this would not be possible
in this case
so this wouldn't be possible
if the pawn was on a7 and not on
a5 actually i'm
wrong so this is not the moment to play
d5 d5 here you could just
take take and you take on
g6 and you take on d4
in fact the bishop e3 if here
jeffrey would have taken d5 you have
this extra move of knight b6
rook b8 takes or a3
you can take or play a3b4
correct that is the difference that in
this case
you can't really deal with this
i mean you have less space and still a
bad bishop on
c8 which wouldn't be possible in the
other case
so d6 was played bishop e3 dc
knight takes c5 rook d8
so it is time for us to observe
situation
who's better and why
from one perspective
might as much better because these pawns
on c6 and a5 are extremely
weak on another sense
white's pieces are a little bit
scattered
so wesley has to organize a little bit
to consolidate so
how can you consolidate if you have a
better position
there are certain steps that you can
take and that you should take
for sure
trade opponents active pieces correct
you should
first of remove your opponent's
aggressive and
good pieces and then proceed
to develop and that's exactly what so
does
he took on d4 rook d4 queen c2
communication between pieces is
important
the rooks are now very much connected
e5 rook d1 and there's a bit of a
difference this bishop is still
very much passive on c8 and that knight
on c5 is just a monster
knight f8
so it's clear that jeffrey is trying to
get
that knight to e6 however
wesley is not having any of that he goes
for bishop c4
one of the things that these super
grandmasters do
is that they try to limit their
opponent's counter play
as much as they can so he could have
played
something like bishop f1 there's nothing
wrong
with that however that would
kind of give an opportunity for jeffrey
to exchange even more pieces
ship c4 queen e7
wesley takes on d4 and there's another
reason why wesley takes on d4
one of them that we already discussed
it's an active piece
but second of all it'll become a target
on d4 this guy on d4
is going to be another target so black
already has
one two three targets in the position
so if wesley plays his cards right this
should be a win
knight d3 just blockading the pawn
bishop g4 and this is the technical
phase
one of those that where vastly shines
the most
so let's try to find a plan over here
it's clear that we're better but without
a clear plan it's very hard
to convert even this position
so another plan is to get the bishop out
and away maybe to attack the c6 pawn
makes sense but black can carefully
defend it so it's not such of a
big idea
um
i mean it makes sense however it does
feel a little bit slow
so one of the things that i kind of see
in this position is
that black's piece is a little bit
scattered right on the rook
the knight and the bishop is all
discoordinated
so we should try and make men's try to
use that fact
and if we notice that we might even spot
the only piece that is kind of fleeting
and is in danger of being sort of
trapped or captured
which one of that can you
think what do you want which one do you
think
it is one that is fleeting and sort of
a potential target
obviously it's the g4 bishop
so once you identify your target you
just need to find a plan
to actually play against it
f3 is way too direct in fact the bishop
is so
awkward on g4 that you want it to stay
there you want jeffrey to make
concession and moving that bishop
himself
because in that way you gain time now
that f3 is a bad move
but it actually helps jeffrey
so instead vastly so played f4
the whole point being if you just laze
around with black
here comes f5 you don't have bishop
takes e takes because
the rook is defended and now
h3 and g4 is going to trap the bishop
notice how strong this bishop is on c4
you can't even save this guy on g4
you're just one move too short of
playing f6
and after g4 this is a typical formation
of trapping that bishop on h5 it's a
bishop trap yeah
so f4 is a very strong move basically
winning some tampi
so jeffrey is forced to move this bishop
yet again
bishop e6 f5
f5 is sort of gaining more space and
forcing
jeffrey to make a decision either you
bring your bishop away but then you will
be
super passive or you exchange but then
you bring my queen
in so jean decides to actually take on
c4
between c4 queen d7
the next move is actually going to net
vastly upon can you guys spot it
yep knight e5 and after knight e5
not only does wesley attack the f7 pawn
the d7 queen the c6 spawn and the d4
pawn r
is all under attack so it's
actually a four-way attack not even a
double attack
so it is rather impossible to defend
oftentimes it's difficult to deal with
double attacks but quadruple attacks
they're decisive so here jeffrey
is just losing a pawn between c7
queen takes d4 rook d8 queen c5
and that's again a sign of a good
technician
wesley is not backing down yes he's up
upon but he knows that he still needs to
be precise
so if he would go like queen c3
jeffrey could start lurking around the
king with queen f2
and hoping for some sort of trickies
so no wonder that jeffrey faced queen c5
instead
bestie is not giving any counter play
knight d7
knight d7 rook d7 as the defender you
are trying to aim for some exchanges
hoping that he could reach a rook and
game
e5 playing on the side where he has the
majority
that's what you should do and that's
what vastly does
rook d5 queen e3
queen e7 h3 again
there's no rush once you get that extra
pawn you have to make sure
you don't give counter play one of the
counterplay that
wesley was worried about is the back
rank
so he goes for h3 and says okay i'm
going to get rid of that problem
between c5 king h2 queen takes rook
takes e3
and jeffrey did succeed in getting a
rokan game
however it is still very much
advantageous
for wesley now if rook d2
then there would be e6 and that's a
problem with this e pawn running down
the board
so it goes king f8 f6
aiming for more exchanges and also
trying to cut off
the king after gfef the king is caught
off
and it's much easier to play the
position with the king
off sides rook d2
rook e5 rook b2 rk5
king e8 king g3 and as you can see
both the grand masters are bringing
their kings in
because it's a rook and game you've got
to bring your kings in
c5 a4 king d7
rook takes king e6 check a5 and now the
a pawn is
running down the board a6
rook a4
and now wesley is at a standstill
but is he what should be the final plan
to win this position this is actually
the final hurdle
in this sense chess is a difficult game
you've got the opening phase
the middle game you still have to figure
out a construction
to get an advantage then you get the
technical part
and the last part of the end game
so many steps just to win a single game
of chess
so rook and games are usually decided by
past pawns so if you play on the side of
the board
it's very much unlikely that you're
going to create a passer
in fact you already have a passer on a6
so you might want to actually support
that guy and if you do so you might be
mightily rewarded
so wesley decided to go on a journey and
head
towards the b5 square
where the king can support the a pawn
check king e2 h5 king d2
and one of the things that sometimes
they don't talk
enough about in rook hand games is the
quality
of your pawns that matter it's not the
quantity
so yes jeffrey might be able to take the
g2 pawn
but really who cares about that pawn if
you can queen the a pawn
okay two king c3 takes rook c5
takes rook a5 note
in the rokan games it's very easy to go
wrong if you will go a7
thank you for the draw i will attack it
win the f6 spawn and you can't win the
game
so precision is still required so wesley
goes for rook c5 check
king takes rook a5 the rook
belongs behind the pawn also it's coming
off this king
rook g8 a7 rk8
king c4 and here comes the king
h4 king b5 king e5 king b6
here here rook f8
and the queen rook takes a8 and here
comes again a big dilemma
which way to take and wesley decides to
take
with the king why because this rook
actually puts
pressure on a future pawn push
so white's main goal is is to stop
black from advancing so it takes the
king king g3
rook a3 king g2 king b7
f5 f4 f3
f2 and here comes the final combination
by wesley so and i would like you guys
to find it it's right to move and
when there's a game what did wesley play
in this position
so whenever you're trying to find a
solution
you should always look a few moves ahead
so yes any rook moves seem
legitimate but in any case i might
promote or just play king g1
yep rook f3
was played queens rook takes
king takes king f3
the goal and something that you really
have to know in end games opposition
it's always important king g1
here actually jeffrey resigned but after
king g1 king g4
white is winning this black king is
supposed to be in front of the
pawn in front of the h-pawn that is
but in this case it's far far away from
that
and each pawn is promoting therefore
this was a crucial crucial win for
wesley so nice little win
by wesley so but this was just the
beginning of the tournament
the other game that was very
important it was the game between
napomniachi and wesley where
napomniachi was playing
white so here
he plays he here he phased e4
e5 knight c3 knight f6
and d4 he takes queen takes d4
knight c6 queen d3 a peculiar choice
by because
messi has already faced this opening
before
in fact against none other than danilo
dubov and what is kind of interesting is
that in that game d5 bishop f4 happened
d e takes takes bishop takes c7
knight c6 long castles
and after a long sequences
of moves actually do above
outplayed vastly so this was nothing new
for lastly so so i kind of
find this interesting that napomniachi
nevertheless
chose this opening because it was quite
clear
that wesley came prepared in any case
leslie played bishop c5 instead
now bishop b4 is the other move knight
e2
castles but bishop c5 is a bit more
circumspect
the point of bishop c5 is here you don't
have this move of bishop g5
because of bishop takes f2 king takes f2
takes f2 knight g4 check and
then i pick up the g5 bishop
so white has to go for bishop f4 castles
long castles rookie eight again
you see very precise play from
move five from wesley so
even though the position is still
sort of unique he's trying to be as
precise
as he possibly can be bishop c5
already kind of taking away idea of
ideas like bishop g5
bishop f4 and any normal
player or amateur would play d6 here
but wesley wants to be accurate
rookie 8 not only does he stop any e5
pushes
he also puts pressure on e4
f3 d6 queen d2
and you can sort of see that black's
concept is a little bit more healthy but
actually wasted one
two three moves moving the queen around
and it just doesn't feel quite right
there should be six
but all that said it's still a very
complicated position
king b1 a6
and here i think napo miyachi comes up
with
a plan that is a little bit
too positional or passive
there's no other way to put it he goes
for this idea of knight
e2 knight c1 which is also sort of
uncharacteristic of
napo he usually likes to go for quick
attacks
he definitely should have tried h4 b5
and g4 trying to
create a pawn storm against black's king
side
and this would have led to double-edged
position
however he went for knight e2 which is
a little bit more positional
and not really in the nature of this
game
b5 knight c1 knight e5
a very strong move by wesley not only
does he threaten
ideas of knight c4 or even bishop c4
but he also hinders any g4 pushes
because in that case
knight takes f3 would destroy
white's structure
so why does force to play bishop g5
because h4 band itself isn't such a big
threat
it goes bishop g5 and bishop g5 is met
by a very nice little move by
wesley so
let's stop right here and try to find
what wesley played in this position
and this move that was played was h6
which might not strike you as such a
brilliant move
but it is why you can't retain this pin
if you go bishop h4 knight takes e4 is a
typical way of winning the pawn
if you take on d1 i take on d2 and
that's
just perfection for black and
in this case i just take and i'm up a
pawn
so this leads to a very good position
for black so white cannot retain the
spin
and h4 which is a typical piece
sacrifice
probably isn't quite that dangerous
because knight h7
and black just has an extra piece for
not much
so here nappa was forced to go back and
in
this regard waste a move bishop e3
bishop e3 queen e3 b4
and even though wesley has the
reputation of being a solid player
he plays quite resolutely in this game
and goes straight for the attack with b4
knight e2 a5 not f4
and he's not even skipping a beat goes
for a4
setting up b3 as a piercing attack
trying to open it up for the rook h4
queen e7
b3 is by the way not the only way to go
in this position he can also go
a3 and create some mating ideas on b2
g4 finally napo actually
builds up an attack but black
by this time is already much ahead
a3 just creating a potential mating
pattern
on b2 b3 and
here comes vastly so the great
it's black to move and
when
what did lastly so play in this position
so we already noted that this b2 square
is extremely vulnerable however
a vulnerable square by in itself will
not win you a game
you have to find a way to get close to
it
boom bishop takes g4
not only does he get three pawns
because after f takes knight takes g4
d4 pawn is falling but he also gets the
idea of queen e5
queen b2 in so f takes knight takes g4
you can't just move around with your
queen
first off you have to deal with these
ideas
but second of all knight e4 is deadly
let the knight c3
check and black takes everything
so queen d4 is played seemingly holding
the fort together
however like as a very nice move
destabilizing that queen on d4
and that is c5
once this queen leaves it just crumbles
queen takes d6 queen takes d6 rook takes
d6
knight e4 and
sadly after knight f2 you can't really
go rook g1 here
because you will face ideas
such as knight c3 check
and rook e1 and you are
sort of struggling to move around that
position
here here here here
actually i can just capture and
you're either going to lose the rook or
get checkmated on c1
let's say take there's mate on c1
so quite a fascinating game
i actually napo didn't play rogue g1 yet
he played bishop c4
seeing that after rook g1 knight c3
rookie one he is losing he ran for this
one but this is
absolutely hopeless takes
knight e2 knight g3 check king h8
and the problem is not only you're down
upon after bishop e8
but your king is so awkward that this
position is just
completely lost so without even taking
on e8
nabomiachi resigned
so quite a good performance with this
game
by vastly so he defended tenaciously
and when he got the moment he went for
that sacrifice
so last but not least i did want to take
a look
at this game between wesley so
versus levon aronyan one of
the highest rated players who didn't
have such a great tournament
this rapid and blitz but again it was
important because this was towards
the last rounds
so in this game leslie chose knight f3
instead of his typical e4 probably
trying to avoid
a marshall or a berlin and looking for
more of a solid game e3 not f6
c4 e6 b3 sort of a raty tabia
c5 bishop b2 knight c6 take stakes
should be 5 all known theory c
takes knight takes d4 bishop c7
but this is sort of a rare wrinkle
in this position that is
played by levonoronyan
knight d2 and here he goes for queen d6
which i don't think is the best move in
this position
but probably levon was more interested
in an interesting position
than actually
equalizing if you're familiar with
iqp positions that is i said at queen's
pawn positions
you notice that here
there's a peculiar move knight takes d4
ship takes d4 and queen d6 and in this
case
the white knight on d4 cannot go back to
f3 and defend this h2 pawn
knight f3 bishop g4 and this actually
leads to very nice play
in this position now this knight txd4
idea
is actually well known from the spillman
short
candidates tournament uh match
that was played in the 90s very
interesting match
if you want to learn more about
isolated queen pawn openings definitely
check out that match
especially that game where spillman was
playing
this iqp structure and knight takes d5
with reverse colors he used the same
concept of taking on d4 and
launching an attack basically
getting rid of an attacker bitknight
takes d4
but okay aranyan actually went for queen
d6
allowing wesley to play knight f3
bishop g4 rook c1 and in this case
mestizo has a solid structure
he doesn't have to deal with any
problems
because if takes you can always take
with the knight and this is very solid
for wesley rookie 8
h3 bishop h5 rook e1
notice that most of white's pieces are
defended
and as long as there is no mate on h2
white has a long-term advantage because
this d5
pawn is weak and that d4 square can be
used
and be blockaded by a byte piece later
on
rook c8 knight f1 trying to
chase this bishop away which is quite
annoying
bishop a5 rook e2
and here actually i think aronyan jumps
the gun
and takes on f3 even though bishop takes
f3 looks tempting
it gives wesley the bishop pair which he
is going to use masterfully it would
have been much better
for lavon to keep the tension which you
should do
if you are playing with an isolated pawn
should have played knight e4
rook c2 bishop b6 and try to put some
pressure
on these squares on e3 and f2 and hope
to
break through with d4 in the future
but levon decided to take on f3 instead
gf
not h5 but again a side note
this was a rapid game repertoire blitz
because this was the saint louis wrapped
in blitz event
it was a blitz so this was a blitz game
so
actually aronyan was sort of
banking on an attack but it's going to
backfire
quite badly rook c2 quite a nice little
maneuver
queen g6 king h1 in f5 king g2
and even though white had to make of
quite a few awkward moves
after another check i can just blockade
it
actually you don't even have to in that
case you will lose the pawn
it's knight g3 knight g3 fg rook e3
you would be losing a pawn but you can
just go k2 and
block any checks with f4
he goes for rookie 6 which looks very
attractive
from afar but it's going to get refuted
by wesley
f4 again blocking off any bishop c7
ideas
rook g6 king h2 queen e4
and this is probably what aronian
thought is kind of advantageous
he thought that oh queen g2 rook g2
that's
kind of a big threat and if you play f3
then you weaken
your structure and i will have enough
compensation
however he missed a very nice tactical
shot
by wesley
can you spot wesley's
little trick in this position
so again this was a blitz game so
that kind of justifies black's play
he was looking for some quick and
aggressive play
trying to unsettle wesley but there was
nobody who could unsettle wesley
in this event
to somehow you've got to stop this
checkmate
and he actually went for knight g3
probably a move that
shocked levon
it's double attacking
levon is forced to take on g3 and the
big move is
bishop d3 he's not even considering
taking the knight if knight f1 check you
just capture with the queen
and believe it or not you are still
going to
lose an exchange probably the
winner skewer of the day
the move that actually nets the title
the joint title with carlson is this
sequence of knight g3 and bishop d3
and after this is just
technique for vastly so takes king takes
g3
this structure is surprisingly solid
there was no way of punishing white for
this little bit wiener between e6
takes king takes rookie 8 rook c5
d4 rook takes c6 and this
is again a sign of a very strong
technical player if you have a winning
position
and you're sure that the technical
position is winning for you
exchanging and kind of reducing the
material is a okay
so he goes for rook takes c6 bc queen d4
f6 intakes a7
and now he's up upon with many targets
and a bishop that is sort of
offsides bishop d2 rook d1
bishop b4 queen d7 aiming for
an end game as quickly as possible and
it is rather hopeless
because not only does wesley have
pawns on a2 and b3 he also has
juicy target on c6
so take stakes rk8 a4
rook b8 rook c7 immediately going for
the c pawn c5 rook d7
and the problem for black is that this
bishop is just awkwardly placed
he still finds a way of getting in there
but after rook d5 rook b3 rook takes c5
you're getting into a position that is
just completely winning this
end game is just completely won not only
does
white have an a passer but an extra pawn
on the king side so
levon goes for bishop b6 but after rook
b5
this is completely hopeless king f7 e4
taken away all the important squares
king e6 bishop a3 and you can notice
that
even though bestie is winning he makes
sure that levon gets
zero counter play which is quite
important
if you're trying to win an important
game
such as this f5 f3
sure b4 gf gf
king g5 and this is the most precise
after bishop e5
levon resigned because
if you don't exchange you are going to
lose the g7 pawn
and the h pawn is going to run
down the board essentially clenching
tied first for vastly so
so i hope you learned what technique you
need
to become a st louis rapidan blitz
champion and hope you enjoyed this
lecture
thank you so much for watching and have
a great day
or night wherever you are take care
[Music]
you